Hey Leute.
Wenn ich mal wieder einen Tag bei meinen Großeltern
bin, dann weiß ich abends immer eines
ganz sicher: Alt werden macht keinen Spaß.
Man ist nicht mehr so agil und lebensfroh
wie früher.
Viele Dinge am Körper tuen einem weh und
man ist auf einmal viel anfälliger für Krankheiten.
Aber warum ist das eigentlich so?
Altern ist eins der natürlichsten Dinge,
die wir tun.
Es passiert uns ständig und jeden Tag.
Und nicht nur Menschen, sondern auch die allermeisten
Tiere altern.
Aber evolutionär gesehen ergibt das nur wenig
Sinn, oder?
Das große Ziel des Spiels, dass sich Evolution
nennt ist am Leben zu bleiben und seine Gene
an die nächste Generation weiterzugeben.
Und diese beiden Faktoren bestimmen, wie sich
ein Spezies fortpflanzt: Entweder mit sehr
vielen Nachkommen und einem dafür geringen
Lebensalter der einzelnen Lebewesen, oder
dem Gegenteil: Lebewesen, die durchschnittlich
extrem alt werden, dafür aber nur wenige
Nachkommen zeugen.
Und natürlich gibt es auch alle Möglichkeiten dazwischen.
Aber diese beiden Faktoren sind normalerweise
im Gleichgewicht.
Eine Theorie besagt, dass Spezies, die sowohl
kurze Generationszyklen, als auch eine lange
Lebensdauer haben, zu Überpopulation neigen.
Was oft dazu führen kann, dass mangelnde
Nahrung die Population wieder einschränkt.
Kann es also sein, dass sich unser Körper
bewusst irgendwann ausschaltet um Platz für
die nächste Generation zu machen?
Ein vorprogrammierter Tod?
… Ja, nichts anderes ist das Altern auf
einem mikroskopischen Level.
Wir bestehen aus Zellen.
Und die Sterben irgendwann.
Jede Sekunde sterben in deinem Körper ca.
2 Millionen Zellen.
Aber es werden auch jede Sekunde 2 Millionen
neue Zellen produziert, sodass du immer ungefähr
gleich viele Zellen im Körper hast.
Auf Dauer führt das übrigens dazu, dass
fast alle Zellen deines Körpers ausgetauscht
werden und du, zu einem großen Teil, aus
komplett anderen Zellen bestehst als noch
vor ein paar Monaten oder Jahren, dazu hab
ich aber schon ein Video gemacht, das könnt
ihr da oben finden.
Das Produzieren von neuen Zellen macht dein
Körper durch einen einfachen Trick: Zellteilung.
Statt komplett neue Zellen zu produzieren,
teilen sich die lebenden Zellen einfach.
Das funktioniert für eine Weile lang super,
bis die Grenze erreicht ist.
Die Hayflick-Grenze, entdeckt 1961 von Leonard
Hayflick, einem Gerontologen, einem Alterswissenschaftler.
Die Hayflick-Grenze beschreibt, wie oft sich
eine Zelle teilen kann, bevor der programmierte
Zelltod eintritt.
Und die ist beim Menschen ungefähr bei 50.
Verantwortlich für dieses Limit sind Telomere,
die Enden von Chromosomen.
Denn die werden bei jeder Zellteilung etwas
kürzer, bis sie schließlich, nach ca.
50 Teilungen eine kritische Länge unterschreiten
und so kurz sind, dass sich die Zelle nicht
mehr teilen kann und abstirbt.
Obwohl diese Entdeckung 1961 gemacht wurde
sind Wissenschaftler immer noch dabei dem
Prozess des Alterns auf den Grund zu gehen
und ihn zu verstehen, aber es gibt bereits
Experimente, die gezeigt haben dass die Telomere
wieder verlängert werden können, was direkt
dazu führt, dass sich die Zellen weitaus
häufiger teilen können als nur 50 Mal.
Könnte das also das Mittel sein, dass den
Alterungsprozess stoppt und jedem die eigene
Wahl gibt, wann er stirbt?
Nun ja, hier sollte man wirklich ganz vorsichtig
sein, denn eine andere Art von Zellen, die
sich auch unendlich oft teilen können, sind
Krebszellen.
Die Tatsache, dass sie keinen einprogrammierten
Zelltod haben und sich immer weiter Teilen
können, ist die Ursache dafür, dass Tumore
erst entstehen.
Es kann also gut sein, dass unser Körper
ganz bewusst Zellen irgendwann sterben lässt,
nämlich damit sich fehlerhafte Zellen nicht
weiterverbreiten können.
Und das ist super interessant, denn genau
wie auf dem mikroskopischen Level Zellen irgendwann
sterben müssen, machen ja auch Tiere irgendwann
Platz für die nächste Generation.
Wir Menschen wurden viele Tausende Jahre lang
im Durchschnitt nur ca.
30 Jahre alt.
Fortschritte in Medizin und Nahrungsbeschaffung
sorgten aber dafür, dass Menschen vor 100
Jahren ca.
50 Jahre alt wurden und heute liegt die Lebenserwartung
für Neugeborene in entwickelten Ländern
bei über 80 Jahren.
Mit dieser Entwicklung geht zwar auch eine
Senkung der Geburtenrate einher, trotzdem
ist die Weltbevölkerung in den letzten 100
Jahren zahlenmäßig explodiert.
Die Frage ist also, was passiert wenn die
Wissenschaft einen Weg findet Telomere zu
verlängern, ohne dabei das Krebsrisiko zu
steigern?
Was, wenn wir ein effektives Mittel gegen
das Alt werden erfinden?
Die Folgen so einer Erfindung, wenn sie nicht
verboten wird, sind nur schwer abzuschätzen,
aber als erstes würden natürlich weniger
Menschen an Altersschwäche sterben.
Das lässt die Weltbevölkerung sehr rapide
ansteigen und zwingt viele Länder womöglich
dazu, das Zeugen von Kindern einzuschränken
oder zu verbieten.
Auf Dauer dürften Menschen nur dann ein Kind
bekommen, wenn vorher jemand stirbt, was dann
nur noch durch sehr schwerwiegende Krankheiten
passiert, oder wenn sich jemand bewusst entscheidet
zu sterben.
Es würden riesig lange Listen mit Paaren
geführt werden, die alle Eltern werden wollen.
Gleichzeitig müssen tausende Schulen und
Universitäten schließen, weil es kaum noch
Kinder gibt, die ausgebildet werden müssen.
Das legt den Fokus viel mehr auf eine individuelle
Erziehung und Ausbildung.
Man kann Kindern jetzt einen einzigen persönlichen
Lehrer geben, der sie dann mit neuen Aufgaben
konfrontiert, wenn es der richtige Zeitpunkt
für sie ist, nicht für eine ganze Klasse.
Wenn Menschen mehrere 100 Jahre alt werden,
könnten sie viel effektiver in ihren Berufen
Arbeiten.
Die gesammelte Erfahrung eines Menschen würde
nicht mehr nach weniger als 50 Jahren Arbeit
verloren gehen.
Das kann ein riesiges Potential für den Fortschritt
der Menschheit bedeuten.
Trotzdem würden wahrscheinlich viele Leute
Hunger leiden müssen und es würde sogar
Kriege um Ressourcen geben, bis sich die Weltbevölkerung
zahlenmäßig angepasst hat.
Und von da an?
Wer weiß, wahrscheinlich besiedeln wir den
Mars und danach andere Planeten um als Menschheit
zu wachsen.
Alles ist möglich, auch dass unser System
unter der Last so vieler Menschen zusammenbricht.
Die Frage ist nur: Wollen wir das?
Ist Altern Teil des Lebens und unseres Lebenszyklus?
Oder sollten wir, wie viele jetzt schon meinen,
Altern als Krankheit einstufen und versuchen
diese zu bekämpfen wie andere genetische
Krankheiten auch?
Die Frage geb ich jetzt einfach mal an euch
weiter: Ist Altern eine Krankheit?
Diskutiert mit mir unten in den Kommentaren. Wenn euch das Video gefallen hat,
vor allem mein Make Up, dann gebt mir einen Daumen nach oben
Und wir sehen uns. Bis zum nächsten Donnerstag, hauter rein. Euer Cedric
Auf Wiedersehen. Tschüß, Kinder. Wiedersehen. Ok, bye bye.